مشهد شريط ل
أضف أنه يعمل
برازيليا تحت
قياس في
وقت الإيجار
ملك
هو
الملك هو
نحن ندعم التطعيم ولكن لدينا
اتخذت الحكومة موقفا ضد
أي جواز سفر صحي
الالتزام المتعلق باللقاح
قبلة نبدأ الوباء الذي ندعمه
استقلالية الطبيب في البحث عن
العلاج المبكر
بناء على توصية مجلس الإدارة
فيدرالية الطب
وأنا نفسي كنت واحدًا
من الذين خضعوا للعلاج الأولي
نحن نحترم العلاقة بين الطبيب والمريض في
قرار الدواء الذي سيتم استخدامه و
في استخدامه خارج التسمية 1
ولا نفهم لماذا العديد من البلدان
جنبًا إلى جنب مع الكثير من وسائل الإعلام
وضعت ضد العلاج الأولي
في هذه الحالة اليوم هذا الحب يذهب
البقاء في العمل أو غير مؤثث به
غاضب جدا هل تستخدم الصوت في
سيارة العام ليست غبية و
ساق نشطة ولكنه أيضا لأنه في
البرازيل هو
من هذا الفرع في الحجم نقوم بطباعة
قصب السكر من البرازيل
انشر الوجه المثلث هناك في ملف
الشعر البرازيل قرأته هنا سيكون البلد bolsonaro
الألمانية في بعض الأحيان
هيلاري الجودو النحيف شاحنة ل
جعل صديق يقع في واحدة من Cerrado ل
التغيير والخروج من ماذا
شكل أو عمل آخر نفس الشيء
لن تخطو أو هذا الهراء
إذا كان راديو جيدا أو جرائم الروك
شبكة تجول هناك أيضا لا يوجد مستقيم
البرازيل عاش فقط يكتب
الإلكترونية هي سوس كورونا ووتش Doo o
فيلم يورك مروحة الطاقة عائلة EA أ
نهاية لاتخاذ
هذا التجمع وعلى من هم مع الأمريكيين
لكني أحب Eloise Bruna senne بعض
الفضول و cronadyn يرتفع أبدا
الابن ممل اكثر منه
تم تدريب القاعدة من بولسونارو الذي لم يفعل
تعرف على الخطة